hey what's up everybody still reporting
on the events that happened this past
weekend at San Diego Comic Con today we
will be talking about Wonder Woman 1984
some interesting events happened this
past weekend regarding the movie one
thing is there was footage shown this is
pretty shocking considering that filming
has only just begun for Wonder Woman
1984 but San Diego comic-con is famous
for studios giving a first look at their
new movies coming out the footage was
obviously still rough but it gave people
a different insight on what the movie
will be like one fan did manage to snap
a couple of photos of the trailer which
are these that you see here based on
what everyone described it started out
in a mall Wonder Woman was wearing her
Wonder Woman costume which is said to be
brighter than before
and based off this photo taken from the
trailer right here it does in fact look
a little bit brighter it goes on to show
Wonder Woman saving a little girl from
two criminals
Wonder Woman crushes the criminals guns
with her bare hands then she throws the
little girl into a giant teddy bear to
get her out of the way and into safety
and as you can see in this picture it
seems to be taken right when Diana has
the guns in her hands Wonder Woman then
pulls out the lasso of truth
lassos the two bad guys and jumps over a
balcony pulling them with him we then
cut to a logo of Wonder Woman 1984
within see footage of Diana running
through the streets very fast to a point
where she's almost flying when one of
the fans was describing the footage that
they saw they said the spirit of the
footage is fun and ironically seemingly
a bit silly and goofy er than perhaps
we'd expect take that last comment with
a grain of salt because like I said it's
rough footage it's nowhere near complete
so the fact that it seems silly and
goofy ER may not really be the case once
it's all complete and edited however
they could be going that way
DC has been pretty dark the last few
years and it hasn't really worked for
them very well and we know that Aquaman
Shazam and Wonder Woman 1984 are going
to be more light harder than the
previous movies that we've seen over the
handful of years so maybe they are going
this way but let's hope it's not too
silly because the first Wonder Woman
movie was van
think so I hope they keep the same
direction that they were going with with
the first one and the last piece of news
that we got which is really shocking and
quite a surprise to me and that is that
Wonder Woman 1984 isn't actually a
sequel it's not a part two to the first
Wonder Woman movie that we saw it's its
own standalone movie gal gadot's actual
words were it's not a sequel and
director patty Jenkins said it's a
standalone tale due to her not wanting
to just keep it going she explained that
she's making a completely different sort
of film to the first Wonder Woman movie
and she made it clear that it's not more
of anything and that it's its own thing
so I'm a little confused
I can certainly grasp the concept of
what she's doing I just can't really
figure out why well I can think of a lot
of reasons why but it's just a very
interesting approach to the movie this
does however explain how Steve Trevor is
back if this is not a sequel and it's
its own standalone movie then
technically the last Wonder Woman movie
didn't happen so if you're basically
going to redo a Wonder Woman movie of
course you're gonna have the two biggest
characters with the exception of Wonder
Woman of course Steve Trevor
who is Diana's love interest and cheetah
who is one of the biggest Wonder Woman
villains in the comics so although I'm
not really sure what route they're
trying to go with this movie I do like
the fact that they are bringing Steve
Trevor back certainly an interesting
move the first Wonder Woman movie was
great in my own personal opinion and I
really hope this one is - I'm eager to
see what happens
what do you all think talk to me in the
comments below be sure to LIKE the video
and subscribe to my channel if you want
to stay up to date on everything
happening with Wonder Woman 1984 all
things DC Marvel and superhero thank you
so much for watching woof woof
[Music]
[Music]
you